heart and we're live we were not you're
lying Deline talk about private stuff
let's talk about I've got this tumor
that is a little too private instead
let's talk about spoilers from this
episode oh yeah although okay just right
now did you also watch flash yet so oh
no I all lash spoilers that's fine I oh
no no do the flashes emit you don't
watch the show in general at no time
like I come home and I edit her like I
respect our front and you work for our
friendship is over it's over now right
like the problem is I'm just so saddled
with making excellent YouTube content
for you guys at home that's why it why
isn't it really good then Oh what is
your gun suck so bad sir oh I see get
this [ __ ] you guys [ __ ] you both oh man
alright guys so as those of you guys
know from my announcement like seven
hours ago protection Java that one it's
basically last minute in the low oh hold
on hold on before you do that I want to
let the people know that ok I'm gonna
spoil this for you is we're watching
agents of shield but here's how this
went down Rob made that announcement and
then said hey Sal and Benny are you good
to do this you want to do that Wow is
already watching it and I was like what
I felt kind of later handle showed up
it's amazing I told him I was like I was
like okay like maybe I just kind of had
it in my head because I do have a
tendency to like live in my own little
world like like I have an idea and I'm
just going to assume that everybody else
knows the idea that i found it is on
total board once for my door yes he hit
he hits up the both of us and he's like
so we're gonna do this like 5pm and
sounds like what do you mean it's a
great episode watching it see it was
honey cuz i was like Celie watching this
yet and he was like yeah and i was like
you're watching it and he's like yeah
and i was like i thought we were gonna
like live stream
I was watching it and he was like what
and then I like I'm like we're doing
that what I thought we couldn't actually
make it work and so I assumed we were
going to watch it and then discuss it
and so I was like oh I better catch up
on the episode like I better watch it oh
my god yeah III didn't even know what
was going on he's like oh we're doing
this at five Benny and I'm like oh we
are are we uh let me see if I'm free
what is like we said that we said we
were doing in 25 and then I answered my
girlfriend on Twitter which was like
what time you do this is my five and
Rob's like hold up we're shooting for
five yeah Rob's of organizational skills
are a little off my organizational
skills are pitiful man like it's it's
the struggle is real struggles appeal
and the this organization is as well
this is just that real I love their
title by the way just so everyone knows
Rob can't show you the episode so if you
don't have it yeah yeah you're just
gonna look at our faces go oh my god oh
yeah running it commentary but but
here's the deal guys so this one is
obviously just like like a test because
and i'm currently refilling my my e-cig
at the moment some of you guys have
asked what it is I'm that i'm using i'm
actually using the Aspire Atlantis which
is a beastly tank be smooth are they I
can go get my little uh my email wanna
pen and then get like oh yeah cuz that's
just legal in Colorado ya know I could
literally get it just be like what we go
into the office I'd be like oh this is
getting so good fine yeah you guys are
flipping on Oh Michael that was amazing
yeah what is what should be halfway
through and be like like you know I'm
gonna order pizza good like water
Domino's like put your freaking credit
card number just out there on YouTube
day dave was lost in the YouTube crisis
and Rob's click baiting got your asking
about Dave Dave's off doing his own
adventures so yes that's I want to
finally address that could be been kind
of avoiding it cuz we we we did we
parted on good terms yeah yeah
but Dave basically can't devote enough
time to two youtubing because he's no
longer injured he's going back to work
so that that's what happened went there
that's all it is yeah yeah um but yeah
so so yeah if this is popular if this is
something you guys would like then we'll
probably do we may do it live I don't
know I mean I don't know if anyone's ok
will do alive oh yeah good line or we
may just do it after the episodes over
I'm I don't know but anyway I'm ready
whenever you guys are so okay so yeah
let's do this yeah ha hulu works I have
it up by the way by the way who is not
funding this so we don't have an
affiliate link of who I can't like I
can't tell you guys you'll get like a
certain percentage off your Katniss
attacked your printer yeah she's broke
part of it this is why I don't have
children and cats well yeah the life
took day what we should do is uh we
should synchronize first off and then we
should tell our people at home when they
can't like so everybody should load up
like everything should be loaded up
first okay so i gotta get perfect
commercials so get past that like a
tower commercial oh I then I veneer like
done that yeah that's like let me give
us again free load up the show and you
people guys everyone should buy destiny
I got a destiny commercial I had like a
jcpenney commercial well we can see what
they're targeting with you I do love
pennies Oh what is this commercial
actually looks pretty epic you can talk
about it I got a destiny one but it's
the old school destiny wanna throw me
the like we're gonna break into the hive
Oh warlock powers oh this is a frickin
Range Rover commercial why is there a
range rover driving through the Sahara
Desert well who the hell is going to
take a range rover through the Sahara
Desert and even if you could what would
make you think you could like to survive
hold on I just thought of something as
the YouTube as the YouTube alliance
while we're waiting for to load I am
gonna tweet it's super effective it see
if you'd like to join us good call oh
yeah it's comic Drake availment be awake
Drake is actually working on projects
all day today him and his girlfriend
getting together tomorrow so he's trying
to get everything finished I was talking
to him earlier oh [ __ ] i'm at the last
time on agents of shield I home I gotta
go back you watched it all you watched
it already I watched six seconds I'm
sorry oh my that is not like me who just
completely was the whole family yeah um
but once everybody's all cued up we will
tell them when to release by guess just
at the beginning just go all the way to
the beginning till you see the shield
and then we'll all count down and then
we'll hit go yeah and then walk away I
gotta get a situation here we gotta get
faust it'll be awesome said is your
european yeah europeans in their names
man it's it's funny but it's funny
because they're colored people make me
laugh like your coat what was it that
michael caine said in the awesome powers
to he was like there's only two things
that I hate oh that's why I didn't find
no other people and the end the Dutch
Faust is just like you rob what his name
is not it's super effective its rhythm
beat music what is it with these what is
with you guys in your musical
aspirations that enter into comics so
here's the deal so once upon a time
before I ever like actually got into
like the whole comic book YouTube thing
um I was like I used to DJ all the time
like i dj'ed at friends parties and
stuff like that like i got turntables
instead of a numark ns7 s sitting in the
closet back there so you cut wax with
the best of them you are you oh yeah
dude man tiesto's got nothing on me like
like Afrojack avicii those guys wait
wait wait did you just say DJ tiesto has
none Jason yourself a man like nice I
guess sucks really sucks i was listening
to that guy back when he first released
like when it was like like tiesto what
was it um live it like the hidden forest
or something like that like basically
back in like two thousand was when i was
listening to his stuff way back when and
such a Sun rises actually got me into
electronic dance music but um not like I
used to DJ all the time and it was it
was amazing I it was really really fun
not just got bored of it so yeah
economics which ever die I'm speeding
tweeted people are coming up with like
all these Woody's things are like
adventure time Adventure Time mommy do
you like which one you do what are you
thinner Jake thin or Jade and for
adventure time do I look like somebody
you would be named Finn what you I don't
know why do I know about a venture tiny
Arbella house I'm a hefty man why do you
think my feet my feet started hurting
like an hour in the comic con I was like
oh my god to lose weight but it's
happening i'm not even gonna go on to
how much you complain to drink um he was
brutal man like i was up I just wasn't
prepared then you complain so much that
me and me and Sal had conversations
about and complained about your
complaint oh I know I already know about
a man like Rob [ __ ] complaining the
whole goddamn time I don't go to New
York Comic Con and awesome colorful
convention and complain you got the
first day the first day was your worst
you've got an hour into it and you were
like I'm gonna go sit in the press box
obviously their favorite attraction at
the show they had a huge wet a built a
booth out of all the supplies they had
DC had like all the bat suits from every
incarnation of Batman Rob's favorite
attraction was a bench he was like oh my
god this thing has all in his arms oh
yes thing for my ass to just sit I could
just totally owned this whole area right
now and he did leave like six hours no
no it was it was it was that and Dave
cuz dey was injured but upstairs in the
press box it was funny because Dave
couldn't walk it we were to look are
they have your garden all the [ __ ] yeah
yeah you do need a Sherpa like in that
the con because you need a son like just
somebody to watch all your stuff because
there's nobody there you guys a chance
see the kind of people that I'm
associating with right now they're
really cool when they're part of the
podcast with an you meet Betty in person
and he's just like yeah Rob condo I've
had to pull me aside and I warned you I
was a dick man you
you were just realize anybody surprised
i mean i was like that he's like hey and
I'm like there he is hey guys on the
same guy when the podcast is after their
first met Vinny man he came walking up
the ramp cuz we were meeting in the
middle of the airport and Ben he's like
like loaded up with everything's like
well I brought like the whole world with
I brought my whole house and so I got
like four bags and like a great big huge
code they weighed like 20 pounds that
about it was huge I had a light leather
coat and I had one bad man i hope my ass
it was like Hagrid's coat many things to
me why you're getting back at me for
being so mean to you guys like okay so
um are we ready to go ahead and launch
this no this is funny or I think they're
enjoying us going on about that bench
was comfortable man like when my feet
were hurting man that [ __ ] was now you
know I'm gonna go I'm gonna put my
friend blasto so we had a friend to pick
us up bring it to the hotel and my
friend he's he's a handy guide
individual not gonna go into who and it
like that but he is a buddy but he can
drive but it's like a transformer
vehicle that he can put his wheelchair
into and so basically Rob set in the
back like a bench with no seat belt and
like just nothing but like metal
contraptions in front of him for like an
hour going at weird speeds with no
shocks man it what man let me tell you
something guys every once in a while in
your life you have this experience and
you ask yourself like how the hell did I
make it through that yeah like how do I
said we trapped him we trapped him with
my friend's girlfriend who would not
stay you guys think I'm bad with talking
as much as I do this girl did not stop
we learned everything from her being
racist to sex stories to like within an
hour her whole life story was spilled
out scooter was crazy as [ __ ] like sure
that's nuts look like she giggles never
watched it so we're good speaking of
crazy this episode is crazy so let us
start it are we employ a ship out okay
he didn't come up so we're good yeah
we've got 150 people in here now I
switch is a lot more than I expected was
160 m 50 i want 160 roster by the way
i'm brooke quick i'm just kids we
haven't done this in a while I just
to say I want a channel a comic story
and if you go to youtube.com backslash
comic story Mike I got robbed there boy
can't argue with that it's called commie
story and if you actually go to Rob's
top channel and you click the right bar
I'm over there now Sal runs a channel
called back / TV little house and Rob
did not put him in the sidebar so you'll
never find his channel no but I think
I'm in the playlist soon for Deadpool we
did a yes I priority and my playlist for
Deadpool so nice and real quick I do
want to say that we are launching the
weekly poll dotnet starting january
first we've got a lot of big plans um
it's gonna be around january not january
first we had to postpone because we have
so many submissions from you guys that
we're still getting back to that we're
actually gonna push back the launch so
we can accommodate everything we're
doing so so it was gonna cook it'll be
over the course of january but it is
still coming we're just like i said so
many submissions so okay let's let's
launch let's get this [ __ ] going alright
okay so if everybody has uh agents of
shield up on their screen they've gone
through all the commercials their their
paused it says 43 minutes left up on the
the thing you got the the eagle there
without a double a dual screen like i
have cuz like poor Sal i do not i used
to have a double screen it was awesome
isn't it um so okay you've got you've
got three forty-three minutes left
everything's all ready to go so 45
minutes in four seconds I don't even say
that but whatever um hey you're um the
sands not gonna come through skype is it
mine is muted okay um but yeah just put
your headphones in I could anybody be
able to hear it okay i will be happy
this if you got this is what we do this
this is actually how our conversations
go this is what this is this isn't a pic
this isn't the weekly poll this is us
just going that's BS on my TV yeah like
this is actually like like you guys want
to know what like the post weekly full
conversation is yeah like this is it by
the way i should also toss out do not
spoil the episode for the people in the
chat who have not seen it yeah he's all
true love try not to ruin it up I know
you're excited I'm excited too special
since I've seen it but uh
yeah I somebody's asking real quick
because they did a few more people jump
in um we don't have a direct hulu stream
so what you need to do is you got to go
to your hulu go to hulu plus go to
recent episodes you'll find marble
agents of shield we're starting at the
beginning of the episode will give
everyone will give every 13 minutes yes
actually what is it what time is it over
you guys I have 5 24 I got 5 I got 324
oh right yeah all right so 230 so we can
get a verte i think i think we launched
a 30 and then we go ok so at 30 we're
gonna launch it will say when but that
gives you guys time to load everything
up get yourself going so you need to
load your own Hulu Plus account Rob
would share it with all of you but they
have a three-person limit so yes do not
have a hulu plus account but for
whatever reason in any other way that
you happen to have procured an episode
of agents uh you should cue it up as
early as you can so which was an hour we
got six minutes yeah that chick was
freaking crazy I'm assuming I'm sitting
in the back of the van like this crazy
[ __ ] is sitting next to me going on
about nonsense dave is sitting next to
her and like Benny sitting up front
where it's safe meanwhile dude who's
driving the car who was who was a pretty
use a cool guy but he was handicapped is
like steering this thing like one of
those [ __ ] claw machines oh my god
like oh he's like I was like we're not
gonna make it like we're gonna die we're
gonna die on the way but it was it we
made it in one piece it was fine yeah it
was it was just like not not having the
shocks was the amazing thing because any
time we hit a bump like you knew it oh
yeah it was rough oh I'm gonna ditch
more to show look at my lovely new
stashing check this one out this was
amazing pretty sweet I don't know I got
to find out which one this is the box is
another room right now yeah and I also
picked up because of my fandom the flash
bust which they cut off right at the
flash is dong so oh yeah for those of
you guys who were following the whole
infinity war series that we're doing
we're probably going to do warlock in
the infinity watch issue number 2 next
since that tells us who warlock gives u
infinity gems to but then for the rest
of warlock in the infinity watch it
stupid like issues
three four five and six are dumb and so
like seven are the ones that actually
pick up during the infinity war event so
we'll do more luck in the infinity to
watch issue number two you and then
we'll jump into infinity war issue
number one which is huge I keep
forgetting those comics you're like 40
pages long scan so that's jimster
because jim Starlin the guy said I don't
know wasn't my issue so starting to
loathe the gyms they're there they're
like dreading the name jim Starlin
because of all the star loan books i've
had them read over the years I mean
they're not I love will the warcraft up
but you guys be upset if i was raiding
what we do this we were watching this
and there are a lot of visuals in this
like infinity revelation wasn't bad it
just went on and on and on and off a
hundred and something pages the only
really cool part of the coolest part of
infinity revelation was when both Thanos
and warlog went to like the others mind
basically like the world that would that
would exist like the universe as it
exists like if they had total control of
reality like and it was really screwed
up and really weird but it was I mean it
was like 160 pages I think or something
like that like it was a huge graphic
novel there's nuts yeah oh I'm gonna
karate did you get a cup minds so I was
doing a suicide squad to put out don't
worry I'm doing marvel zombies but I was
doing Suicide Squad zombies i'm so tired
of the regressor I don't like Marvel
Zombies it's not as good as you guys
think it is it isn't it a little too
two-second rant I'm breaking Marvel
Zombies marvel zombies has like a very
very very very very very very fine slim
storyline and the rest of the book is
the Marvel Super Heroes eating each
other I don't what are you alright guys
welcome to the complete story for Marvel
Zombies spider-man a doll may Captain
America eight tony hawk a Tony Hawk at
escape he all lead into his mouth
totally honest iron man I don't know
what you already but you do I let me
know cuz it would last night on the
flash we had firestorm and I was already
doing Suicide Squad because the
announcement of the casting do you want
firestorm or Suicide Squad is the next
know your universe they need to have
Tony Hawk play iron man and he's on the
hoverboard from Back to the Future to
you know that would be amazing
like that would be so beast is not good
now an almond of Randy mood every was
like do marble zombies like to watch
aunt manie Silver Surfer congrats that's
not even yeah I mean Marvel Zombies was
cool up to a point but when it's like
everybody lives happily ever after
because they're like we can control the
hunger it's like oh my god really that's
working never happen but he's not even
doing that the only way that they could
nope I don't like I i I'm doing the
first trade because people keep asking
for and that's it i'm not doing the
follow-on for where we control the
hunger and fight the zombie horde and
yeah cuz it get stupid it gets so stupid
yeah victoria hug skateboarded into his
mouth over the last minute for the last
minute yep yet the last minutes one year
ago i'm actually really excited I don't
know it's whatever actually I I will say
I've already had this spoiled I got like
bombed with text messages this morning
yeah I know I ignored everything that
had to do with a pod I should've that
was part of the reason why I had to
watch it because I knew that like every
every subreddit every like web page
would be like here's the thing and I be
like thanks I have warded the Marvel
subreddit like like the plague man I was
like no way cuz it's gonna be like what
do you guys think about like what just
happened a few minutes ago and it's like
no right not all that hey don't don't r
/ comic books no you know what I'm not
even gonna know it's we don't have
enough time for us our o goddess our
aunt yeah 530 you guys ready to go there
we go wait wait you got a countdown Oh
fine i already started it okay already
ten nine eight seven six dozen 2016 15
oz empty three four three two one go
alright alright just fainted out and
Coulson is uh doing his present top
talking don't is it a whole time last
time on you know some people red eyes
wrong spaceships in on earth black Hulk
angry oh no it's grant Ward want fried
chicken are we supposed to do this like
mystery science theater are we supposed
to do this like don't talk what are we
doing I I mean like I think the cost out
things we just want to talk over any bad
just matter is whatever transformers
it's Starscream
I really liked you better think that
they would have more technology like to
like instead of like Atari beeping you
know bust me in every TV show whenever
anybody hangs up a cell phone it goes
boom I'm like yeah Batman's playing
galaga nobody knows she I want you
official water that's what I get look at
them playing look at them playing with
the with the green screen there yeah i
gotta say these these planes look pretty
damn good every episode there's a plane
and it's nick not there but it looks
really good do you think they have like
some kind of sponsorship with like I
don't know aerospace something or other
public space X 1 would be really cool go
okay may I love me may is a state
affairs yeah she is finally getting into
the mainstream comics and it's about
damn time she's really hot too no
question Rob you had to go there Rob he
always goes there just I always go there
I'm putting on subtitles cuz we're
talking closed captioning oh how do I do
that oh I see boom it's probably gonna
help honestly definitely oh now i can
show i love i love it oh yeah that's
right go Starscream nice nice cloak no
duh that's what someone said visual
confirmation for drug case let's just
assume i wonder if they looked with
their super awesome cloaking device not
know they must have gone warp drive yeah
there's no jet falling anywhere let's
just assume that they got blown up yes a
system that's nothing left there's no
way that they would use that super super
high-tech secret cloaking technology now
can I can I say I is she just mentioned
that one of the main characters there
Skye i I've always hated that name sky I
can't wait for them to give her her real
name me too figured out if anybody
things guy I'm be like her name's
crystal that's what I'm waiting for oh
you are
oh oh no be quiet chat don't give it
away what what I am I looking at chat
I'm not looking off as a ladies man
right now I am a man's man you better
believe it is man does anyone else feel
like we just stepped into the fourth
Indiana Jones movie yeah clarklake
grades looking a lot better than
Harrison Ford these days i'm waiting for
here's a forger clark gregg days like
this Agent Coulson is becoming one of my
favorite Marvel characters yet he's
easily one of my favorite Marvel
Cinematic characters oh I i I'm also
really really happy with what they're
doing Bobby Moore's with mockingbird she
is she's pretty good and I think she
could easily switch into the movies well
you know what else though I III don't
know any agrees with us no but I like
Patton as a pot Patton Oswalt scared me
too man yeah the brothers yeah Oh dum
dum doing we all forgot he's a son of
one of the howling commandos I forgot
about that yeah he's the son of damn
what is his name that's gonna be out a
link him in with agent Carter I
guarantee ya all I could yeah I'm pretty
sure they will oh my god that'd be
amazing if they cast him is this like
grandfather and it's still Patton Oswalt
Gabe something or other okay so they're
gonna they're gonna um have timed
explosives that makes me feel like
somebody is going to try it at the last
minute like make it work again okay hold
on hold on can we all agree that agents
Sims and Fitz need to get back together
and fix this whole freaking tired but
also he's coming along and just say you
know what guys just go in the room and
just [ __ ] for like happy just going on
another way sure arguing and then Cole
suspension just flips a condom right at
his face ya know what could be in a
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's so much tension
between these two that we don't need
like I liked him better when they were
the happy-go-lucky fun goofy goofy group
for the last season I did not I thought
they were AB not
I really like their I'm I like that
every season or every half season we're
in a totally different place like
everybody is in a totally different
headspace in a different place as a
character and like Fitz and Simmons like
I really expected them to never change
and they they did in a big bad way and I
really respect well they changed but I
don't like what they did with them i
don't i don't like the changes it's you
know what it's if if they make good on
it it'll have been totally worth the
ride just like I hated sky and now I'm
like what's gonna happen to this poor
guy is unless annoying now this year oh
yeah she's definitely a lot less
annoying and I like the whole thing with
her dad or dad's just like sekonic yeah
look up mockingbirds hiding something
from not Hawkeye haha I was disappointed
there's no references to hawkeye with
Bobby maybe it doesn't have any teeth
they in the last episode they were
talking about how like you know
something was going on that was like on
the side and you don't know what it is
I'm like wouldn't it be cool if she was
like oh I was married to clint barton
ryan wants to know why Fitz is regulated
to the friend zone [ __ ] that's why I
don't have the balls to walk up the
Simmons would be like you know what like
listen let's just go he did he did do
that and then he like got brain damage
so oh that's true oh now we have an
awkward hug awkward haja turn heads it's
not into this likewise why are you
hugging me do you really need to push my
boobs that close to you like can we have
a little space between us I really
expected her to give him like a
blackjack the back of the head at this
moment I'm really glad that did not
happen cell phone beeps like it never
does haha cell phone beeps by the way
iphone product placement does it I love
the cheese lisa spun taxes it's a thumb
drive she's still like working for Hydra
I wonder she's like a double agent no
triple agent at this point I think well
I guess I mean she know she's mocking
bird she's not gonna she's not uh
Jessica drew hey nobody would give it
okay if Jessica drew were in this show
and then she got blown up or like died
in a fire like nobody would care they'd
be like well you know what that's what
ever ya cuz Jessica drew sucks
who's me mmm oh so now we're gonna play
the game of May [ __ ] up no you didn't
may you did an amazing job and your
beautiful woman yeah you don't make
mistakes Clark Gregg that certain people
died it's not your phone you're the
Calvary they haven't called that in a
long time I'm like damn it I like that I
like that nickname now we get the
awkwardness dude is it just me or okay I
liked warden I don't like the the swish
they did I felt that it was a funny
switch yeah this guy this guy's like a
poor man's award like like the other
ward was really awesome and now this
version where he's just kind of like
well you know I'm kind of do my own
thing but I'm kind of a good guy but I'm
not really a good guys yeah what I
really chillin but i'm working for Hydra
right now the constable getting shot
yeah I uh I like it he was an underwear
model in the beginning of the show and
now he's something else and I like it I
love that scene in the lab a couple
episodes ago I don't feel what he made
is when he made his brother dig his own
freakin grave I was right out the man I
don't my children did he kill them in
his family anyway I just feel like it
was a forced transition like they were
like we need to have a guy turned bad oh
no you didn't see it coming it's warren
buffett Appa I feel I don't know I feel
like it was Wilson's I think was a
little man this is this is we're gonna
find a school here we go here we go like
this actor by the way sky wait here we
go here we go sheesh commercial god damn
it oh so i got walmart what'd you guys
get I got laptops it looks like in it
looks like a pc tab I got apple products
so yeah here you know what will act out
the scene okay so your sky is Sal ok ok
ok and Rob you're gonna be warned sky I
wanted to I wanted to tell you about the
importance of your heritage and that I'm
your father does like the honey what am
I mean it I'm not sure another
commercial yeah where's this is the
paper this let's go hey money to water
three commercials in a row
but I don't pay for cable so that's
horseshit um Oh sky I wanted to tell you
the truth about your heritage we're
actually from weapon x watching did I'd
be so pissed is like and your name is
really like whatever the name of the
chicken 23 yeah you're very you know
what I was relaxing you know be amazing
if they were like you know what you're
actually an eternal oh my god what a son
last year I mean that wouldn't be guy
were actually builders now allow me to
explain what builders are well you know
how like that the universe has life well
we're kind of the ones responsible for
the heads which is like [ __ ] you
jonathan hickman the Celestials are the
reason why we have life in the universe
not these stupid builders yeah by the by
the waist guys you're a blue alien like
the smurfs yes yeah okay okay it's like
oh here we go oh my how do you guys buy
a second it looks like oh my god Oh Raj
was a prick don't get angry he gets
angry [ __ ] happens
skype my name's Bob Oh Cal and I'm
sweating profusely Cal boom you know who
it is there you go damn it though is it
Marvel explained dr. Jekyll yeah it's
calvin zap oh yeah that is a she's
[ __ ] Daisy god damn it you know what
man happy ass wait i'm looking to
something so the big buildup is this guy
can make earthquakes that's awesome not
really more importantly it's inexpensive
it's an easy battle you know who else to
make earthquakes like avalanche [ __ ]
avalanches that's what I'm saying like
people that can do earthquakes suck is
cool hey we got Tara over and Teen
Titans yeah Tara sucks to chat is quite
cool he's [ __ ] talking about almond
cookies and flowers a man what the hell
is this guy's jeez try to connect with
his [ __ ] daughter you sad about Jack
he doesn't you show up be like by the
way uh where you go like let's name all
the Inhumans we can speaking of which by
the way uh mr. Hyde is not inhuman know
whose mug oh he isn't no no he's just
hideous now no I think not we least that
was another episode his wife was in was
was was special or get up Daisy Johnson
quake boom she is really sweating I
thought saying it's a very heated any
dude Vinny is a very sweaty man you were
stolen from me students cool he really
plays like crazy label like heap no I'm
saying he's exactly like both hahaha I
knew that boat have you confirmed she he
this do this actor really plays like
restrained insane well like where he's
just click like if you were like you can
act crazy now he'd be like yeah you just
explode yeah
he's just he's always walking on a
knife's edge yeah it's amazing this
guy's a real actor I don't know what the
hell I've seen him in before but like
every time I see him a nice as a quake
is cool better this entry drops the mic
oh my god get the hell out of here
crimson I that's crazy yeah so do you
think he's gonna Hulk out or is he just
gonna be like oh just I mean I think he
just keeps I think he's just all so
strong I don't think he like turns into
anything he's just there just kidding
that'd be cool they did it yeah what is
that actor from its bugged me everything
that's are saying I don't know look em
up hang on
Oh No
you ain't going nowhere it is your
destiny girl good I MTB just reminded me
there's a Paddington Bear movie coming
out oh I'll go dude I'll camp out for
that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i'm not going to
kick it over at paddington beer I was
gonna say a very large man came to front
of a thing for having to bear with just
one guy really offer at all there did
she dye her hair a different color since
the beginning I thought so like her hair
was darker it was yeah we need to
lighten is that was the little didn't
know when she was on your death their
liking where our shield agents ever
they're like oh my god there's guys
walking towards us like keep our heads
peeked out staring at him until at last
minute let's make a huge jackass they're
like the least famous Twinkie yeah
that's the 1i known from the hell is he
now she's gonna out of the blue have
seismic activity like photo sphere
well we oh man I'm students sorry well
I'm just a big [ __ ] oh I'm emo aha Kyle
MacLachlan is with somebody said thank
you yeah Kyle my Glock what all is
really annoying I don't like a really
angry little bit that hide beats though
I like beat him to death like literally
yeah beating him to death from a
freaking is from Twin Peaks where any
well that helped us out your lamb [ __ ]
you really he wasn't lost their so here
was on Sex in the City 20 I never waddle
in the city and someone kitchen where
does keeps yelling showgirls hmm why did
that easy why did you watch showgirls
cuz I had was her name from yeah that is
only be saved by the bell naked that
doesn't that doesn't make it redeemable
oh he screwed lift is cliff van der cave
from the Flintstones movie there you go
that's where we all know how the hell
did I forget that my god hey once those
movie with Oh Donald Rosie Rosie
O'Donnell
why don't have a feeling he's saying the
shield came in it was actually Hydra
pretending to be shield at that time
Hydra like Daniel Whitehall when it
showed it was old yeah yeah a guy that I
thought it was until the end of the
episode that you learned it was his wife
yeah oh yeah that's right yeah the the
the the Chinese girl who didn't never
spoke with she like never aged yes okay
she was touch the obelisk a never got
older yeah uh Jamie quirk Maximus the
mad is the only like bad in human like
alien humans are pretty tightly stop
really bad though and lockjaw lockjaw
super evil evil evil man he's trying to
take over the world so many times yeah
if the only oh my i'm gonna do a video
of lock jaws original sin okay the one
time he barked no did you notice the
goat really read pages of him looking
for Ribery to bone yeah oh my god that's
how many just the opportunity there was
was crazy cause like sup here we go
here's the irrefutable proof that her
name is Daisy how he sing he's with he's
he's humming the song Daisy ah from
Butch and Sundance and 2001 a Space
Odyssey in the worst way
yay looking forward to see not creepy at
all hahaha enjoy murdering people yay
hooray for murder well think Dwight Hall
was like a Nazi and he murdered and
mutilated his wife so I mean like well
you know two wrongs don't make a right
you know electorate you have to admit
though by making her get my wife we
pulled out of like the nobody's ever
gonna guess this one thing yeah well the
other thing was they could also do
anything they want and no one will
complain as long as she turned into a
superhero and yeah like she has powers
right
as if like things don't go normally so
yeah they always go Sam self they
they're literally everything lives on
Cape Horn it's so South that is if it
goes normal South just kind of hang
around if it goes like Robert a South
get the [ __ ] out of here oh really right
on top of that I'm alive again
Australian or whatever the hell I was
supposed to be yeah I don't know what
that was you know I don't you know that
Patton Oswalt shouldn't you know that
shield has tech that can drill through
volcanic rock womb a change of plans i'm
phil coulson let's do this [ __ ] change
of plans changing do without falling
Tony Stark and he's gonna come by and
kick ass that would literally solve this
whole problem in like a minute yeah but
that was agent usual problem [ __ ] this
i'll call Jim Rhodes and he'll come and
fix this problem but this is the problem
with all of what with all the superhero
stuff like there's so many superheroes
and they never just call each other yeah
i know that's a the whole world's gonna
end it was called the avengers in
literally the most egregious one was was
iron man 3 like a cab to i get but Iron
Man 3 he's fighting volcano man and
you're like no Hulk nobody I he hates my
two least favorite people in this whole
show it's a it's totally not German
Whitehall and koi McGee also known as
Rayna I want these two to die so bad
that is cool i like where she is not
quite lady is it was a bit douche she
she thinks that she's playing all the
angles when she's totally behind the
eight ball like every [ __ ] episode so
obnoxious but she does her job well okay
what's going on with this chick cuz i
know i like is she ever gonna remove the
face of my way she can it it melted on
her way onto her face or something like
she literally can't take it off with the
freaky robot voices Patton Oswalt yes
and as she's like evil may
nice probably shouldn't have done that
oh my god it's not turning me to stone
Oh genius oh wow yes ah that's awesome
waited war to just join her team like
all right I was always on her team cuz
word really wants to tap it yeah man I
want to tap that sky daisy-chaining
house he wants to kiss the sky I got
digiorno and now I want pizza tonight I
got Rob Lowe here comes another 200
minutes of commercials yeah it's in 90
seconds what's wrong with you know he's
like oh there's a lifetime in the
digital age man we're also paying for it
why look where's the money go you're not
paying for you took Rob's shut up Rob's
paying for shut your mouth yeah shut
your [ __ ] mouth yeah white hole is is
interesting I wouldn't mind seeing
whitehall like vanish off the face of
the planet like from the team yo but
he's not that bad I'm he's obviously a
character that will probably come to an
end like with season two like he'll be
killed off entirely I don't see why the
whole like sticking around for a long
haul why the hell would you put white
hole in the movie yeah but we're back or
sucks I'm not that good I'm tired ten
seconds left pause yours Sal I have
purchase tickets online hang on i'm
going back boom let's go back ten
seconds what are you guys only have ten
seconds let me know what we're bags just
add irrelevant to you know hahaha none
of the ads I'm like blue the ads
irrelevant to me there's no way to
synchronize this is there not anymore
it's all out of whack now yeah i just
started up I'm paused where we don't
brought right now I'm i was looking I
got 10 seconds left Rob Rob be [ __ ]
with this job home so I can lube oils
rap rock you break my balls a little
buzzed as soon as soon as it starts
probably breaking our balls Rob Rob ok
so we're I just like weird you started
for me like skies looking at the screen
or looking at somebody yep I got what
yeah consist play huh
is it play oh my god Rob you just mr.
Ravi was so amazing blackpool just
killed everybody so whitehall used the
organs of Skye's mother to get young but
he still can't fix his eyesight see that
chick looks like a female sub 0 0 t even
Whitehall was like what the [ __ ] are you
doing ward yeah oh my god shut up like
every delivery you like that coming
secure god they have super strength yeah
just put handcuffs on him he can't get
out of those haha yeah he probably
hasn't mastered how to free himself from
handcuffs oh I like other the Jets
invisible but you can still see it well
that way we could see it it's like the
Invisible Girl my name is the
invisibility and call of duty advanced
warfare people put it on the run around
like and I see you no problem look I got
a head shot haha when are they gonna
kill this limey bastard because he is
not a character with a name nameless guy
yeah what is his name right I'm a member
he's the red shirt he's gonna die after
they've established some kind of
relationship with Bobby yeah you'll feel
bad that he dies but at the same time
you're also like she has to marry
Hawkeye so that's the end of you Oh
it'll be that simple we're just gonna
get the hell out oh here's one useful
person in two anchors that's great you
know we could do guys like what you're
just [ __ ] leave haha just know I at
all we have to blow up the channel and
keep people from getting to the city
even though they know where it is now
and can come at any point maxi on their
backs down there don't go back we're
having an alias moment
having an alien's woman previous scene
is brought to you by Ridley Scott yo the
crab there's some kind of light film
here it reacts when I by the way this is
grant Ward all the way I'm a super spy
but this is totally gonna hold me I'm
gonna be good don't worry about it oh
yeah no he's playing possum I love how
her eyes are mismatched like they're not
level yeah that's brilliant Oh comply
hey let's bring up that plot point you
hated from like a while ago
see what the heck is it going to owe it
is going to turn them
dude you're mr. hi just punch I'll
[ __ ] put your fist through his head
I think I like the name sky better than
Daisy I like quake better quick wins a
ball yeah oh by the way don't kill the
prisoners or do anything just leave them
here just unwatched it'll behind we've
like one person guarding like one of the
best prize ever in the history of the
world yeah I you know I guess I don't
know sky is not a [ __ ] bye
the tunnels are older than the pyramids
but were the first people to ever set
for them how the hell did they get built
the free no first that's it that's the
new name yeah that's the sound of you
getting ready to die
hahahaha so that was good yay so they
like me as would like Deadpool is that
who he is now Judy would you what would
you do if that was the spin they give
him I would be by the way that won't it
work Ward is taskmaster that's who he is
oh I could see that I could totally see
you daddy coming taskmaster right but he
hasn't displayed by the fighting prowess
a taskmaster yet are you talking about
evening it's killed like a van full of
dudes and the pats master like like his
muscle memory kicks in to where he oh
jana becomes the person who's fighting
all he has to do is like go to the
Terrigen mists and they gonna make
taskmaster in a human or some [ __ ] i'm
doing the models will gonna convert will
anybody complain you ruined the
taskmaster and you it's just the excuse
for everything at this point yeah
everything it doesn't turn into that
it's going to again because they can't
do mutants and mutants is the catch-all
they use in the comics yeah uh yeah well
by the way that person's of you and oh
that explains everything then the house
of him Bend this was like you know what
there's too many [ __ ] units let's
just yep that's the internet'll i know i
can see you from far away but why can I
hear you from far away that's what does
what the evil grin I just change already
like this is dead that doesn't change in
this is just miss her this is not
imposing ok ok kill this guy reward is
MODOK huh thank God yes you don't owe
you [ __ ] Coulson damn it yeah oh god
Coulson's gonna pay for it now he'll the
man I was gonna kill now I got a you're
welcome Coulson air commercials yep
Coulson is just a joss whedon quip
machine I plan to murder somebody so
I've got 60 seconds istana be arresting
I'm getting I got a hundred seconds
double whammy doc I got 23 seconds see
all I can't get all the commercials I'm
really gonna do after 19 seconds when I
guess the next thing I'm gonna pause it
I mean no just
as soon as it comes up yes I mean what's
the commercials overall I'll plaza I
just got a good times chicken tenders
commercial don't worry crimson night war
does not actually mode is there good
time anywhere else good i'm only used to
go to look like Ward light disappears in
the mid-season finale then like at the
beginning of season 3 he shows up and
he's just like in a floating head yeah
and like shooting and my last commercial
is BP nice I was a phone of some kind BP
showing how they help everybody cuz yes
still trying to like her like recover
from the oil disaster God well it ain't
working it just started I like that was
not a hundred seconds well stop it then
we're all right I got to throw I can
tweet the ad if I want cuz that's Oh
something I want to do All Right girls
already 10 two three go I don't like
that I'll blow your head off to you yeah
you should totally do that
yeah Coulson
it's evil may yeah Coulson's like I have
amazing aim when it's convenient exactly
now I can't shoot [ __ ] yep that's that's
how he's gifted that's his miracle why
does she give a [ __ ] about whitehall
look at offset she is so I'm guessing
that the woman like his wife never aged
because she had a healing factor so I
just say Coulson probably has the same
thing her novels and Whitehall has a
healing factor now yeah oh you're so
clever lady the way mine too bad pip-pip
a a an accent makes you sound smarter
you just talking a little [ __ ] like
Coulson and mr. Hyde yeah what's tits
the two dads you gotta have like this
you know it's the good dad and the evil
dad for sky or Daisy or whatever don't
worry Skye I'll save you I'm madly in
love with you your butt is amazing I'd
like to touch your hiney I'm a butt guy
you have a good but sit down we don't
want to injure your butt really [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah [ __ ] it is awesome oh you
got blood like he's even like 10 she was
looking shot warned he was not prepared
haha was it won't go forward what don't
you get with oh look Coulson's
apparently at MMA on the weekends oh the
it's the funny thing happened on the way
to me owner like short fellow yeah get
like jump in the air you can like
[ __ ] do Trinity moves oh [ __ ] or she
gonna shoot my dad oh that's all I
wanted to hear baby
and I beat people to death when they
take things for me like a parking space
that was my god damn pencil teach me so
I threw his car across the parking lot
and be done with it with a becky yelling
why you gotta do a headshot headshot no
but what like board his chest yeah no
you wouldn't dare
Williams like she doesn't want to kill
him really that Becky's like willow body
shoot three times yeah no she shot him
three times in like the midsection
that's a roll the good meat is you know
what if but I don't want you to die just
want you to bleed out and painfully yeah
this is this is like some weirdo like
compound there's no like med kit you
never know they just lie those around I
love that noon I just sitting in the
corner I could I can kill word though
did a good job okay word pissed me off
ulsan really trying to stop her oh god
he is really because I think I know
where this is going let's hear it man's
gonna throw it out there no I'll go out
there I'm gonna wait ah only one got
through yeah he's wearing like body
armor it's stupid yes kill him oh wow
whoa oh you know I used to bang another
version of you with you d not ugly one
by the way if we ever do anything i need
a brown paper bag that because uh cuz i
really thought of score underpass that
is really [ __ ] up looking just I'm
just your eyes don't even match girl the
real problem is that you picked at it
which is really an issue yeah like don't
it I know it itches I mean option B is
you can just take the mask occasion and
Batman Forever he was like it's never
gonna heal if you don't stay on spending
wow we just busted out a Batman Forever
quote oh yeah that movie was awesome oh
crap the obelisk on what are they gonna
do with the obelisk are 0 TT 0 it's down
there the double dub oh it's yeah it's
right over here took it yeah what is her
power don't even know who she repeller
is being really obnoxious but still
being on the show
a paris being a stupid [ __ ] oh no its
back o goddess Blackpool yay beat him to
death that's not really ruffle other is
not gonna be Black Bolt already know who
blackballed is yeah Oh black balls
believe in diesel is me yeah the cast in
diesel is here forgot about them another
character doesn't another actor under
the character for him to doesn't really
talk cold is think that you got really
good care director like imaginary shows
anything whoever does they cast a play
Medusa is gonna have to be an amazing
actress I will say this the hold on dia
I watch a lot of Hulu and there's not
only this many commercials in to share
it turns holy crap love that theory that
Asian 33 is Madame masque that's awesome
I hope that happens Madame masque is an
old iron man avengers villain way back
in the day yeah name's Whitney uh
something I Whitney's her last name is
her character is actually in the comics
age again oh yeah I know no no 3333
whatever her name is well no 47 is in
the movies I I think agent 33 is in the
comments too but whatever um [ __ ] whose
are dead uh-uh dr. duh nefarious uh I
don't remember Chad who's ur dad who's
who's Madame asks dad because they could
use her in the show to talk about if
you're talking about dr. nefarious he
was the one that fought the x-men and
issue number 94 i think it was when the
all different x-men I had no idea that
Asian 33 was the girl to beginning that
got brainwashed oh yeah so we've seen
her without the the may mask oh yeah
yeah they cast her and then they I guess
got rid of her it's like we just want
another maid cuz made reasonable we only
wanted to pay whatever you guys back on
the show already okay i'm at the last
six is six seconds of my ram commercial
alright so was letting ryan go back
who's my head of nasty not read Hawkeye
not anymore
does anybody miss Ross Kenan just said
whitney for us thank you sir no no age
of 47 or dr. affairs are from ratchet
and clank and hit man and they were in
the movie captain america i'm just
saying agreed go down there tell us what
happens knows what is happening we're
done waiting for this [ __ ] dr.
divinity as much as i enjoyed this
season there's been so much goddamn lead
up to this yes yes but you know what
lets it better if you look pretty good
payoff it better you know the ending
does it is the payoff good i'm playing
with it I'm doing it for your benefit I
don't want to ruin it world will be
Maximus the mad no I will tell you this
guy's uh Fitz and Simmons totally [ __ ]
in one of the chambers in at illin at
the end of the episode though okay well
it's about time we got around well now
we know it's Attila day thanks buddy
they don't really have an awesome no no
we got no time left can we gotta do it
now Fitz and he's image was good the
mixed up whatever will do dude he's like
oh she's like Dodi you don't even have
to try and talk we got this yeah and
then the useful one trip goes down there
instead god I hate you Rena feel bad for
Mac I liked him yeah I like all these
guys like they really like this is a
good ensemble I like everybody on the
show except Rana except for she's not a
character is this like a fifth element
like oh she does need some fire yeah
imagine her pocket I ain't gonna fire
yes got it so strip gonna blow up zose
hahahaha an art trip arm just kind of
flies like needs to have it like mcneese
Nikes like run up on on rain and just be
like yeah white dude that's what that's
what a Chris Tucker did in the fifth
element yeah
all right we got seven minutes other
guys something oh oh no no no son back
that's not a I said back up with its red
contact Meg
what he's just not destructive anymore
no I guess not well no he's he's the
guardian he keeps non-special yeah I'm
coming in he's like a century yeah
you're gonna look like a Kree sentry
where does she buy her glow sticks I
won't glow spheres like that mm-hmm does
a standard-issue cube are those of
shield Martin yeah uh twisted twisted
says that this could be a transformers
city they could yeah I don't think it's
actually a tell'n Decepticons oh my back
Oh God love her put the [ __ ] thing on
the pedestal I was away with [ __ ] don't
talk about it anymore
and
here we go
he's gay how he can she can't study but
gone too far like the the show's already
did knows how sick we are waiting for
the [ __ ] yay it's too late Reina she's
going to die can ring a dying cuz she
just died right now that'd be so great
Cole said you are knotted at you when he
just like got punched in the back once
yeah yeah I'm so bad at this I really
should go back to the last line of work
well trip you [ __ ] no trip you're not
all hidden I like short ribs like oh
this might not have been a good idea
well is it gonna take off for all those
are tears and crystals I bet I bet they
are what would do oh [ __ ] Terrigen
crystals you're all wrong it's
kryptonite this is this is blue
kryptonite yeah it makes you inside out
what I don't think blue curve that I got
that no it's just you know whatever not
crap we're supposed to touch it yes the
Terrigen mists
luckily Rob's like two seconds ahead of
me so just let me know everything that's
gonna happen oh you dead girl oh [ __ ]
everyone dad I'm touching this [ __ ] yeah
don't touch her oh no oh [ __ ] by the way
I can round house like a boss [ __ ] a
really [ __ ] yeah are they dead
wow it's in him yeah oh wow trip no oh
yeah I forgot that's what [ __ ]
happens with it in humans well not
necessarily there's some glow yes your
face no that happened in the Inhumans
comic too I remember return the stone
now they get into cocoons yeah it's just
an outer layer no it's he dead or is he
gonna change he's part is gonna be dead
ocean yay earthquakes definitely has
powers now shouldn't you have just
broken trip yeah see ya
what about the weird face Raina got on
our though with the whisker [ __ ] there
she is Shh they're gonna hide it until
later she's gonna come back looking all
badass is the [ __ ] well they don't want
to spend a lot of money on like what
they don't know what she's gonna look
like yet but okay I got a commercial do
you guys get a commercial yeah it's
gonna pop a second yeah my friend is
dead Oh [ __ ] trip yeah that's like
the worst that's the worst trip is so
great he was a great character you could
have killed either Fitz or Simmons and
we'd be fine I know but trip I was all
set to be sad that Mac died gran gran
says I another black guy bites the dust
what the hell man you got to do whatever
you must be the black people don't we
don't care about a person either yes we
don't need diversity in this Casper yeah
it's literally girly was tivities we
don't know who Rayna is the broil IIIi
think I know who r en treinta is she
spoke Laura I think she's minxy think
soo is Mixy Mixy is a handmaiden of uh
what's her name of Medusa she looks like
this [ __ ] that she's covered in when
she's like transforming here I'll jump
in the chat and put and put the right
spelling
thanks / if you look at ming see she's
like she's got like she could grow wings
if she wanted to she's got like kind of
like weird like [ __ ] on earth at like
Raina did yeah man this done and out the
castle black characters man they're
slowly killing them off yeah oh yeah up
we're back so i'm not i'm not i got 30
seconds okay possum good damn it's just
pause it takes a shame I'm pausing it my
god man mr. black says always the black
always black God where we heard man 5438
a zoo blood and go oh no I was a little
bit of his phone owe you five for the
last minute you're only gonna do that
now knows a little bit those little on
okay well I'm a couple seconds behind
you guys but it's whatever oh my god row
that works amazing oh my god round
actually don't know what the hell's
going on at all I'm just turn ahead
there's another one Leah there any
humans all over the place what oh no
it's guy with noise who is he nobody
this is the way see now that is why I
don't give a [ __ ] about the Inhumans
because who could forget the great
eyeless character because I was an
hour's oh not being able to see I'm
sweating look at that [ __ ] whatever soon
right that episode it was alright I like
I think flash was better I do somebody
in the chat brought up um that Mac let
trip by huh only I got in now was that
was was Mac being distracted while by
Coulson at that point I don't think so i
think Coulson got in act like or got by
after a vice
back strip he might just appear to be
dead but he's actually changed into
something completely different maybe
he's shrink because well not all the
Inhumans like or have blatantly obvious
powers you know say that turn its man
someone says we should do we should do
flash anybody even keeping up a flash
other than me oh I don't mind I don't
mind watching it out of out of a at a
sequence i don't care i mean we could
just jump into flash if you guys it on
hulu homebodies playing this but i'm
gonna break it down I feel like it's all
right no we don't do that right now I
feel like we're gonna do a show why
because of whatever he whatever he reads
comes true yeah yeah the blind guy yeah
the blanket pocket okay I know a little
bit of seen both of the mid season
finales and I'm gonna say the flash one
was better really yeah boy dopest agency
we had the Terrigen mists go off cool
and they just left it at that you know
the flash we had the introduction of a
new character a villain that's been
built up in the last nine episodes we
had like a breakdown of the entire story
plot it was great I think we got AI
think i think this episode is pretty
sweet I think it was good i'm not give I
thinkers on everything it kills a bunch
of characters I hated which works have a
rain is still around um we did lose trip
at least for the time being hopefully
that the theory forgotten eggs I hope
not but I think that my dear I mean like
I was listen when they killed Victoria
hand at the end of the season whatever
from the first one I was like I was like
well she was clearly a life model decoy
they're not gonna just create Victoria
han and then kill her in three episodes
oh they did and I was shut my mouth I
was [ __ ] wrong like uh so yeah you
know I was quick ack i was cake oh he
that the actor for trip is got an IMDB
entry for the new avengers movie cool
well yeah you can't really rely on that
though because i am DB can be edited by
anybody yeah so somebody can just put
him in there it's true i mean like i'll
be i'm down like yeah yeah I wouldn't be
disappointed no no I hope they bring him
back because I'm ready for them to
establish cosec to put Coulson
shield into more Marvel movies again I
don't know why they're so against it I
really do I really do think it'd be
awesome if they brought them into it I
know because like what I really don't
want to happen is they canceled the show
and then have like uh like just Coulson
show up and have like stark or I or II
aura or [ __ ] Steve Rogers go like wait
what happen to your team and you go like
oh I that I sent them all home like it's
over have you know like what there's all
these characters all sent them all home
yeah I'm all good have been yeah they're
all regular people now I i sent them
away but see here's here's a cool thing
see this is what a lot of people i think
lot of people aren't paying attention to
this like this is one of the really cool
things um what Marvel is doing like
Captain America 3 the Civil War yeah
alright we know that it's gonna be civil
war but obviously you can't do the
entire civil war conflict in one movie
no no the third one I think they are I
think they are gonna do it one movie I
don't actually only they are I don't
think they intend to like I totally
they're gonna do it just cuz what's
planned we already know it's coming
after it you can't leave the Civil War
hanging and then go move on well yes
here's no see here's what I'm saying
like we all know how civil war started
like natural blue Nitro blew up and
Stanford Connecticut and initiated the
whole thing I think whatever happens in
Captain America 3 is going to be the
marvel cinematic universe version of
nitro blowing up at Stamford Connecticut
and then I think that like with all the
subsequent movies after Captain America
3 you're going to see like this
undercurrent of things involving civil
war we're like superheroes start to pick
sides where you constantly have Captain
America like defying shield and things
like that and then you're going to have
the infinity war and then so on and so
forth and then the phase after that I
think it's just going to be like a whole
series of movies based on Civil War you
know why I think you think that because
you don't want Civil War to be broken
down into an hour and a half movie is no
possible way you can if you think if
Civil War this becomes Tony Stark and
Iron Man and Captain America fighting
like it like I say it is yeah that would
be a huge disappointment did you imagine
I grabbed about dining with them just
like fighting for 20 minutes of the
maybe they'll be so disappointed as you
hear did you hear about the Sony hack
yes that's a lot man that's why that
apparently Marvel tried to get
spider-man into civil war and Sony said
no I don't know they said no I heard
that it was going to happen not only
that apparently like the the Sony
executives are getting back together
again to like make another spider-man
trilogy yet they wanted Marbles input
normal was like [ __ ] off yeah Marvel's
like go [ __ ] yourselves by the way that
Sony hack is spectacular because it's
showing just like how totally like what
a [ __ ] that company is and how
like they have no idea what they're
doing yes oddly enough but it but for me
it shows like since Spiderman was
supposed to what was clearly actually
going to be in civil war which shut my
mouth I was totally wrong but now that
spider-man will not be in civil war my
theory of daredevil being replaced we're
replacing him is might still be in
effect that's all the popular thing i
think that uh it I I think it's going to
be a self-contained movie cuz like why
would you spend that like they have to
establish spider-man in that one movie
and have him do all those civil worries
[ __ ] like yeah yeah hold on hold on I
looked up Sony hack have you guys seen
this Sony is planning to make a
crossover movie between the men in black
and jump street I did hear that let me
tell you something why would I am out of
out of the three you have three men in
black movies and 221 Joe Street movies
and I like two movies from one of those
franchises and it's not that it black
yeah I like one minute black movie and
the other two are garbage so whatever
[ __ ] it do it I don't care I think of
Ghostbusters for all I give a [ __ ] like
I mean it so [ __ ] that whatever anyway
well um here's the problem with not
having spider-man in Civil War oh it
doesn't matter it's in that dude it
matters the relay were not spider-man
wasn't even in the treatment for civil
war for the original comic they weren't
even gonna do spider-man like he was
even gonna be in it casada read the
script and then last minute was like
make spider-man take off his mask
literally not even in the plan
you know what the significance of that
was like society not like like no
society in the comics were like well
hell I mean if spider-man like that like
the most reclusive person ever in terms
of his identity never revealed his
identity comes out and reveals it in
support the registration that it must be
worth something but it seemed to change
anyone's mind it didn't know my God look
support like there's a public support
people were upset because Spiderman was
involved with it in spite him as a known
criminal it in fact didn't do anything
but sabotage the Registration Act no no
no support heroes you know superoes
think I just worry about Santos fighting
that's all it is in superheroes fighting
every reals funny it's going to break
I'm marking my words I'm saying it right
now yeah okay I'm putting this on the
table rock I'm betting you five hundred
dollars like a reason well that we can
actually do 500 knots that silver war
the captain america movie will be
started and finished in that movie I'm
nya great that bit because you're
probably right I'll take that bet
because because it could be they could
do anything I mean like that the fact is
it's so tumultuous they could literally
make the final decision right before
shooting so we have no idea yeah that
yeah they really could they could come
back and just like rewrite it halfway
through Oh sony could sony could right
before shooting of Captain America 3 go
like do actually okay you can have them
and they'd be like okay like I mean it's
it's yeah no one no one really knows
like I don't I have no idea what they're
going to do but what I do know is that I
would be very disappointed if the entire
civil war conflict starts and finishes
in Captain America 3 I and here's my
ears the actual reasoning for it and I
am more than just super girls fighting
at that very end of the whole thing okay
if you take civil where you take out all
the underlying tones you dig on all the
spin-offs in everything like that civil
war breaks down to jest superheroes
fighting and we know for a fact
superheroes fighting generates money
hence why Superman vs Batman is titled
Superman vs Batman and not Superman and
Batman punch each other for a little bit
and then they go fight lex luthor so
we're gonna fight lex luthor they're
gonna fight it what's his name metallo
or something yeah over there that we
already know they're gonna team up but
they still titled that movie superman vs
batman now anybody who has not actually
read civil war see civil war as
superheroes punching
each other that's all he see that
everything's a most notable aspect of it
right well I was they not the selling
point you stay and that's what the
selling point is so what I think is
because everyone I mean I get tons of
comments do support i don't know like
civil war they know that they put civil
war on it is going to sell the movie but
they've already got plans to do infinity
war and other stuff we already knows
where they're going they won't be able
to drag on civil war let's see we don't
know what they're gonna be doing after
infinity ward well I my opinion I think
they're gonna throw civil war into that
one movie that's all you'll ever hear
about it because in order to properly do
civil war we need a lot more superheroes
than we have available to us right I
agree with that and that's why I don't
think they're gonna do it in one movie
because right now like your your lineup
like the Marvel ssin and people people
tend to forget this because of like the
complexity of the movies and the stuff
has gone on in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe you've got a like three like
three people who have powers and agents
of shield you have the Avengers and
that's it yeah yeah that's tell you're
right it's very bare-bones version hours
yeah lil is it out that's why I don't
think they're gonna because what we made
some were so amazing was the entire
superhero population divided even if
they introduced 50 more superheroes you
still wouldn't have the impact that you
got from Civil War they say why I say
like I think civil war is going to take
place after the Infinity Ward because
remember like you've got the Netflix
series coming out which means yeah
Captain Marvel you've got daredevil
you've got black panther movies coming
out you've got dr. strength the
structure strange movie coming you've
got like all these movies coming out
with all these new superheroes are going
to introduce to me it only makes sense
that civil war like the actual main
civil war conflict could be stretch over
a single phase and it would take place
after infinitive work the only reason
why I don't think they're gonna do that
is because I I personally don't think
they would cash in the name civil war so
early if that was the case that's the
biggest thing cuz civil war should have
been the Avengers civil war that would
have been the build-up and they could
have done like Captain America or
something else but but the fact that
they're putting civil war on the captain
america movie says to me it's gonna be
kinsella contained yeah I will let me
let me let me throw something out there
just really quick regarding I'm gonna
put to bed the Sony thing with with
spider and stuff with this comment that
Becky says where she was like why
doesn't Marvel just put spider man the
movie anyway and pay the fine because
like whatever it would break some kind
of like contract deal and like
they would have to pay a hefty fine
disney has such insane lawyers and i
know this from personal experience of
some associates who have done business
with disney legally and disney's like
legal team is so feared dreaded and
imposing in the UH like entertainment
world that that really would be the way
to do it like [ __ ] glad-handing and
making and trying to appease anybody
you're paying like you know people to
get whatever to get what you want the
first place if you just do it and then
say whoops and then a sony just sue them
like well whatever i've already made a
quadrillion dollars and we can just we
can just go to court for the next 25
years over this one decision i made yeah
i am you know what days but i highly
leave sony would though Sony would
invite them will they they would fight
them to the nail but you're talking
about like disney money like at the end
of the day like when it comes down to
apples versus apples sony does not have
disney money no and they don't they did
more importantly they don't have
disney's legal team and the disney
lawyers would would put sony out of
business I think would be like it would
be like the cold war like they were just
out spend Sony it was nothing I mean for
the leave you look at those those hacked
emails those people are like how the
company even functioning ya like hey
there you know they get people who are
like why are we why we're still making
Adam Sandler movies we're like losing
money hand over fist we don't even know
how to make a Steve Jobs movie they've
already made one and we're still trying
to figure out how to make it Steve Jobs
movie like [ __ ] you so I know the reason
why I don't think they will do that is
they want they wouldn't go to sneak it
in Oh Nick it oh no they would do it
yeah they were just they would have the
bastard reminder it'll be a lot of it
yeah do you all like a comic she'd have
spider man standing right in the middle
of captain vista middle hire me yeah the
shield web iron man poster ends it and
Sony would go like are they serio they
doing this are we doing this okay oh we
got a badass okay yeah well they do be
amazed injunction so they could release
the movie and gentle and so forth but it
wouldn't happen yeah yeah that now that
mouse is beast as William Dublin but
anyway yeah let's not listen is creating
we're creating a whole new discussion
we're turning in a weekly poll although
weird is Louise we're doing yeah I've
gotta jet anyway so able to do anymore
this I mean we now be going for an hour
and a half for a show that was 45
minutes okay let us know in the chat if
you guys want us to do stuff like this
more often like with the flash or with a
30-second tried anything like that do
what I already said to the flash oh your
poor Constantine that isn't cancelled
even though they stopped production
after 13 episodes no yeah which is dumb
they're like order to see how it does
it's not cancelled always wear yeah it's
guy stuff to watch it once they announce
that I stopped watching I'm like all of
course of course you did cuz i watch the
pilot and I'm like this shows [ __ ] I'm
not watching a show yeah the show I like
the concept I like that they were doing
with it but the moment that they said
they stopped production I'm like I'm not
gonna get invested in it so no it was
gonna end [ __ ] that well that's the
thing i got i have firefly syndrome like
the only reason why I got into agents of
shield is because Disney owns ABC and
they just won't cancel it until they are
there are seven seasons a castle leo by
the way I like castle but there are
maybe five seasons of castle we're on
season 7 oh well that's kind of like
supernatural supernatural had an amazing
first five seasons every season after
that while I'm still watching it has
been nowhere near as good as he right so
you know and I could be like that you
see that was like now we signed him on
for 12 seasons why just do something
else on the end no unless it was on like
sci-fi or ABC I don't trust that they
will keep it going like there's no way
honestly as much as I like Constantine I
wanted to shut down so CW can just do
the self-contained universe no seriously
cuz here's my favorite theory of that
before we go a to cuz if Constantine did
well and everybody else started buying
up DC TV show rights ok Cece don't give
a [ __ ] they're just want everybody there
brother by [ __ ] oh they're making their
making a Krypton show on sci-fi they're
making the Supergirl show on some other
networks you've got at all I looked into
this now CBS owns sci-fi and CW oh so
they're all they're all allowed to be in
the same universe that way I cool but
you have been at work now I see and that
way CW does not
into the Super Hero TV show network yeah
Carol but yeah I got boobs on Fox I want
that to go away to excite I want one
company to have control the TV show I'm
fine if we have movie universe TV show
universe yeah don't give me nine TV show
Peter / exact know that's the multiverse
cells gonna be my question like does
anybody watch coffin at all no I did I
like to season the mid-season thing I've
nothing watching got the middle I don't
watch it got it got a lot better it did
oh really I don't see it going anywhere
still but I got a lot better figured out
then I'm gonna check it out tonight see
what I think about so okay all that
we're doing wii bowling a weird right
well we're this is the wrap up this is
yeah this is this is episode so yeah
just out of question for you guys do you
want it I mean we can do the weekly poll
weekly but do you want to see like two
or three episodes and roms channel just
us be a thing about comic books all week
yeah I mean we can I mean that's I'll
tell you what what we could do is if I
weekly if we're gonna be like like the
flash or we're gonna do light the
lantern we can do those over in your
channel since you're predominantly like
it's true your DC yeah and then it does
a shield we can do on my channel do I
get a plea maybe do a weekly now you do
that only people seem to love it man
they really seem to enjoy it Oh flash is
gone it's old Federer though that's
right that gives us plenty of time to
get caught up on everything yeah shields
gone until March yeah well but he have a
shield is replacing the with agent
Carter I know it just looks great that
it looks great good do agent Carter that
mean I we should do agent Carter likely
seven episodes not bad we can totally do
it yeah all right let's Rob of them
let's rev up we have a day so we're
gonna do it like they're listening into
our business plans now here's what we
should do guys uh what do you think
about me doing an episode on your
channel Robert ha salad I you should
join em across something it down to four
episodes week no my 40 through my 10 4
k's everyone just said yes to watch just
talking about comics oh my god what we
do this 10 week old life is bullshitting
about garlic we'll just do weekly for
monday weekly for wednesday weekly for
friday long stirs hilarious do the porn
parodies 2 i'm not watching porn with
you can i'm not that's not we'll go back
to those old jokes guy down jacket
is the counter which one's gonna start
dragging it next but uh oh my god hey
guys welcome welcome to us watching
spider Bay aside if we're gonna be
anyone bring this to an end because it
should even be weird yeah rossouw
started I did I did that started so it
really wasn't even Sal it was a comment
started with yeah they starting it flame
then I bolero we could do arrow to will
you do arrow that's that's not saying we
can do area we can do the flash in your
channel and then we'll do agents of
shield and agent Carter on my channel
okay we'll talk about all this right now
we should just try and start just doing
10 just start doing more weekly pulls in
general the daily pole they want us to
do the daily pull me to really do the
dick I just had an idea monday through
friday we do it at nine a.m. in the
morning we're your guys for your drive
to work just let never becoming like a
radio station where it's like welcome to
the morning comic roundup i'm talking
about comics coffee we're gonna probably
call dude you just aim to the show but
comments and coffee that is such a
[ __ ] perfect name for that g 0 if you
want / sediment Oh Robin all the comics
and coffee somebody regarded it doesn't
have to be daily but we need to at least
one day a lot of the week do comics and
coffee we gotta do comics and coffee one
the other way not many on a Friday we do
we get even copy Dodger with her coffee
times be like hey guys coffee joke the
comics holla onyx oh my god you know the
porn commentary oh my god ever got a job
yep and what we see here is that she
hulk is getting banged from behind by i
try out a camera jenner leave spiderbabe
can bend that way [ __ ] i can't
believe that no Hawkeye would never know
that is not what matters for Hawkeye
that is not what an arrows for this
one's go over three neram and all that
note we should go what the hell explains
rule 34 no dammit internet rules all
right I'm gonna bring this video to an
end because shits getting off on in a
really weird direction right now wait
hold on I got one more thing as anyone
else her panties okay go go
anyone has really seemed to love this so
we'll be back when I want comics coffee
now it's a real show goes I guess we'll
be back when there is a comics and
coffee there is coming to coffee know
there's [ __ ] down well we'll call
ourselves the real comics and coffee and
your comics a coffee all new comics and
coffee coming some coffee now now some
coffee oh I'm looking at it there is
yeah that comedians in cars getting
coffee with Jerry Seinfeld that's a
great show that is it yeah it's amazing
oh alright are you serious here yeah I
like the child ok I find comedians
fascinating anyway on that note we're
gonna go again for the ninth time guys
thank you for joining us today as usual
I'm betting for the comic story and go
to youtube com backslash comic store
rien uh it's a wonderful channel and I
do such much better content than Rob Sal
does TV little house where he does much
much better than both of us it's
youtube.com back / TV little house he
explains to all of his friends what
comic books are and you guys know Rob
he's my books but 10 wrapped up yeah i
just read everything but the stream cut
the student ok ok ok ha that's you guys
live god